Es war wohl eine fatale Kettenreaktion - eine
Tragödie, die ihresgleichen sucht.
Ein US-Forschungsteam hat jetzt die ersten
24 Stunden nach dem Einschlag des “Dinokiller”-Asteroiden
vor 66 Millionen Jahren rekonstruiert.
Ein Bohrkern vor der mexikanischen Küste
gibt Hinweise auf gewaltige Tsunamis und weite
Buschbrände, die die Erde fest im Griff hatten.
Wie genau können wir uns den Tag vorstellen,
an dem ein Großteil aller Dinos sterben musste?!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Dieser “Dinokiller-Asteroid” vor 66 Millionen
Jahren hatte es in sich.
Das hat jetzt ein Forschungsteam durch die
Analyse eines Bohrkerns aus dem Chicxulub-Kraters
vor der mexikanischen Küste herausgefunden.
Demnach könnten die meisten Lebewesen im
Umkreis von mehreren tausend Kilometern um
den Krater herum innerhalb weniger Stunden
nach dem Einschlag gestorben sein.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Forscher, Sean
Gulick: “Nicht alle Dinosaurier starben
an diesem Tag, aber viele von ihnen“.
Doch wie genau liefen die ersten 24 Stunden
nach dem Einschlag ab?!
Die Ereignisse sind wirklich kaum vorstellbar:
Innerhalb von Sekundenbruchteilen wurde wohl
die Energie von - ACHTUNG - zehn Millionen
Hiroshima-Bomben frei.
Klar, dass das in einer riesigen Naturkatastrophe
enden musste.
Zusammengefasst hatte das wohl nicht nur gewaltige
Tsunamis, sondern auch ausgeprägte Brände
und eine enorme Abkühlung des Klimas zur
Folge, die sich vielleicht sogar über Jahre
hinweg zog.
Das US-Forschungsteam hat die ersten 24 Stunden
nach dem Einschlag des Asteroiden reltativ
detailliert rekonstruiert: Im Golf von Mexiko
entstanden bereits wenige Minuten nach dem
Einschlag gewaltige Tsunamis.
Verursacht durch den plötzlichen Versatz
großer Gesteins-Mengen.
Nach dem Kollaps des rund 100 Kilometer großen
Primärkraters, bildete sich ein Kraterring.
Die so entstandenen Tsunamis haben nach Ansicht
der Fachleute schon nach drei Stunden auch
entferntere Küsten erreicht.
Bis auf die Höhe des heutigen US-Bundesstaates
Illinois könnten die Wassermassen damals
vorgedrungen sein.
Doch es blieb nicht bei einem Tsunami - höchstwahrscheinlich
waren es mehrere Tsunamis, die durch den Golf
von Mexiko rasten und Flutwellen an den Küsten
verursachten.
Der Einschlag führte zu Erdbeben der Magnitude
10 bis 11.
Eine globale Katastrophe also.
Denn auch weit entfernt von den Küsten wurden
wohl komplette Landstriche überflutet.
Doch als wäre das nicht schon genug Horror:
Parallel hatten auch unzählige Feuer und
eine gewaltige Hitze die Erde fest im Griff.
Es handelte sich um ein feuriges Inferno,
das durch die Hitze des Einschlages und die
glühenden Partikel ausgelöst wurde.
Diese gingen weit verstreut auf der Erdoberfläche
hinunter.
Und das wohl bis zu tausende Kilometer verteilt.
Dazu heißt es in der aktuellen Studie: “Allein
die Einschlags-Wolke erzeugte genügend thermische
Strahlung, um Vegetation im Umkreis von 1.000
bis 1.500 Kilometern in Flammen aufgehen zu
lassen”.
Doch dabei blieb es nicht, denn Gesteinspartikel,
die durch den Ausbruch hoch in die Luft geschleudert
wurden, regneten wieder auf die Erde zurück.
Sie entzündeten sogar noch in mehreren tausend
Kilometern Pflanzenmaterial.
Doch wie lässt sich dieses Szenario durch
die Analyse eines Bohrkerns rekonstruieren?
Konkret handelt es sich um einen Bohrkern
aus dem inneren Krater-Rand des sogenannten
Chicxulub-Kraters.
Dieser Einschlagkrater hat einen Durchmesser
von etwa 180 Kilometern und liegt im Norden
der Halbinsel Yucatan in Nordamerika.
Unter Fachleuten zählt er zu den besterhaltenen
Einschlagskratern weltweit, da er unter Sedimentgestein
begraben ist und so vor Erosion geschützt
ist.
Der nun analysierte Bohrkern wurde bereits
2016 entnommen.
Und er enthüllt wirklich aufregende Details
über den Untergang der Dinos.
Dazu Sean Gulick: “Der Bohrkern dokumentiert
die Ereignisse direkt aus Ground Zero.
Damit erzählt er uns über die Einschlagsprozesse
aus der Position eines Augenzeugen.“
Vor allem die Ablagerungen ermöglichen es
den Experten, die Ereignisse zu rekonstruieren.
Schon in den ersten 24 Stunden nach dem Impakt
des Asteroiden kam es wohl zu einer Ablagerung
von mehr als 130 Metern an Material.
Eine echte Premiere in der Geologie, denn
eine derart hohe Akkumulation wurde nach Angaben
des Forschungsteams bislang noch nie aufgespürt.
Gefunden wurden unter anderem Trümmerstücke,
Sediment, zu Glas erstarrte Gesteinsschmelzen
und geschockte Quarzkristalle.
Der Einschlag führte zu einer gewaltigen
Explosion, wodurch Sedimente und Grundgestein
ausgeschleudert wurden.
Nicht nur der Asteroid, sondern auch der Großteil
des Untergrunds verdampften dabei.
Und das hatte Folgen: Laut der Fachleute waren
es höchstwahrscheinlich deutlich mehr als
325 Milliarden Tonnen Schwefel, die in die
Atmosphäre gelangten.
Von diesem Wert ging man bislang aus.
Doch im Krater selbst blieb durch den Einschlag
kaum noch schwefelhaltiges Untergrundgestein
übrig, wie die Analyse jetzt offenbarte.
Und das lässt die Fachleute daran zweifel,
dass es bei “lediglich” 325 Milliarden
Tonne Schwefel blieb.
Der aktuellen Studie zufolge müsste es eine
deutlich größere Menge gewesen sein.
So oder so: Die kühlenden Schwefel-Aerosole
sorgten für einen langen Winter und dafür,
dass kaum noch Sonnenlicht auf die Erdoberfläche
kam.
Dazu schreibt das Autoren-Team: “Unsere
Ergebnisse stützen eine solche Sulfat-Aerosol-bedingte
globale Abkühlung und Reduktion der Photosynthese
als wichtigen Kill-Mechanismus dieser Katastrophe”.
Bei der Analyse des Bohrkerns konnten die
Experten aber auch Kohleablagerungen aufspüren.
Dabei handelt es sich um Brandrelikte, die
entweder vom Meer in den Krater geschwemmt
wurden oder aber durch die Luft dorthin gelangten.
Sie offenbaren, dass Gesteinspartikel, die
zur Erde zurück regneten auch noch in mehreren
tausend Kilometern Entfernung Brände entzündet
hatten.
Auch noch Jahre nach dem Einschlag wüteten
wohl Feuer auf der Erde.
Zudem konnte das Forschungsteam dicke Ablagerungen
im Chicxulub-Krater aufspüren.
Diese stammen wohl vom Wasser, das an den
Küsten zurückgeworfen wurde.
Diese enorme Wellen überfluteten den Krater
und das Wasser stieg am Rand des Kraters um
mehr als einen Kilometer an.
Klar ist also: Das Leben auf der Erde hatte
kaum eine Chance.
Schon die Ereignisse, die kurz nach dem Einschlag
auf der Erde ausgelöst wurden, führten wohl
zum Tod.
Die Organismen, die die Tsunamis und die verheerenden
Brände überlebt hatten, fielen dann dem
Einschlagswinter zum Opfer.
Denn der senkte die Mitteltemperaturen um
mehrere Grad und sorgte zudem auch dafür,
dass die Sonne mehrere Jahre verdunkelt wurde.
Den Untergang der Dinosaurier fasst Experte
Sean Gulick so zusammen: “Sie wurden erst
gegrillt, dann gefroren”.
Was wäre, wenn die Dinosaurier nicht ausgestorben
wären?
anklicken, anschauen und Astro Comics TV abonnieren!
Hammer Kanal, Bis dann, bleibt dran!